hello and welcome back to iron lung no
there isn't a major update to this game
except that there is by definition a
major update to this game with lore
now i don't know if this is worth a full
video and if you're seeing this then
that means that it is worth a full video
because i wouldn't do that to you it's
strange how popular this game is except
for the fact that it's absolutely not
strange how popular this game is it's
very good and i like it and it's really
cool and the whole universe is
captivating but also i want to point out
that i realized something i'm not saying
that this is exactly what it is because
it's not but thematically i knew this
rang of bell and i did not mention this
in my previous video
scp-354 you can even see in the picture
here there's kind of a similarity in the
a
aesthetic of the game in that blood
ocean blood river blood lake in scp-354
blood ocean the whole universe however
is different i'm not saying it's the
same i just think it's cool because if
you guys want to you should definitely
read scp-354
it has in it log of exploratory mission
354 alpha 354 alpha is an exploration of
the entity known as scp-354 where they
go into the blood
lake and what do they go in it in the
only thing you can a submarine it's not
the same obviously but i think it's
really cool and if you want more of iron
lung again not saying it's an it may be
inspired it may not be inspired it made
i don't know i'm saying this is also
another cool
experiment and a cool bit of story if
you want something else now i'm going to
go into this right now and i'm going to
look for this lore this is laura we
already know about this is already lore
lordlord lor lalor lore now let's see
what else is waiting for us at the
bottom of the ocean there are apparently
also some hidden achievements which i
was pretty sure that was the case with
this game that there would be some
hidden stuff because it's a large ocean
it's quite large and the points
and the thing about it is
the points
are not the entirety of the ocean
well my lighting just isn't correct for
this
that's better we're now at the bottom of
the ocean which means
that it's time to get here two weeks ago
we conducted
leading to the discovery of the fourth
blood ocean right you can't navigate by
site pay attention to your coordinates
and consult the map the proximity
indicators next to the sub control will
trigger if you're getting too close to
an obstacle
so
what we have here
this is what's new a computer coi
informational terminal this is a local
database be sure to update before each
descent last update today 5 378.
354.
query help
um info
list
can't do that uh
help me
uh i'm screaming and crying
all right so i don't know the queries to
use for that and i don't think that
there's going to be any queries for that
which means that i
generally speaking
m open to exploration
and see there's there's markers on the
map here of places to go but there are
also tons of other things here like
what's in this alcove up here what's in
the bottom right over here what's in
this little nook here right but let's go
explore
okay so what i'm going gonna do is i'm
gonna try to go to
uh actually i'm gonna just go first
thing i'm gonna do is i'm gonna turn
around what the hell is in the back of
the starting area that's a good question
i did no extra exploration when i was
playing this the first time and it's
it's a tragedy that i didn't because
there's so many
like questions that i have now that
we're here because
technically speaking
creepy
creaky kooky
cool and kooky so we need to go up to
200 180.
i'm wondering if i should try to follow
the noises because there are a lot of
noises and i was saying before that i
didn't know what they were all about and
they may not be at about anything at all
you may not see it as a face it may not
be about anything
but you never really know
do ya
i'll update you if i find anything
oh blood ocean okay whoa there actually
are things
here if you type blood oceans
an unexplained phenomenon that has been
identified on four separate moons since
the quiet rapture moon at
80-5 moon z-8 are the most notable
locations as they are under control of
the coi enough research has been
conducted on the blood itself to
determine that it is indeed human blood
but we have not discovered where it
comes from or how it keeps its liquid
form the ocean at
at-5 is of particular interest
moon 80-5 redacted this entry has been
redacted see blood and food
okay moonsy eight monsieur the sight of
one of four known blood oceans and one
of the two such moons under the control
of the coi moon z8 has historically been
used for the realization of coi
convictions until the discovery of the
moon at5 okay
the coi what is that the consolidation
of iron or coi is a brotherhood of three
space stations and two spacecrafts found
on the principle of collectivism and
ruled by the popular vote of all
citizens numbering 257 at the time of
the century its name comes from the iron
and steel materials its two main
stations are constructed from and the
principle of unity and togetherness in
the face of menace from other
surrounding stations
such as eden oh other stations hang on
i'm gonna i'm gonna get rid of this
blurp blooping let me move my position
now that i've found how to look up
information i do love that that is
unexplained of how to do that
i don't love that sound that's outside
of the submarine right now okay
so what is eden
space station eden is the largest
man-made structure that still exists in
the wake of the quiet rapture it was
formerly the main station for mars and
the populace still maintain a strong
sense of martian patriotism and
independence making them a constant
threat to the sanctity and security of
the coi it has occurred in the
population of 468 and has the only known
remaining trees in its interior garden
the coi considers eating a threat to all
collective well-being after their attack
on the filament station
interesting i'll get to the uh let me do
filament station first filament station
was the fourth and largest space station
the coi until 362 eic when tensions
between the coi and eden erupted in a
nine-day battle on the station the
conflict battle ended unresolved when
eden troops resorted to sabotaging the
station's reactor resulting in a
critical breach
redacted the breach left filament
station uninhabitable due to high levels
of radiation and it has sat empty since
hmm prisoners taken during the conflict
have been undergoing conviction
realization in the years since with the
final ones expected to repay their debts
and integrate into the coi society by
381eic
so that must just be the year e i c
epoch of interplanetary colonization
epoch of interplanetary colonization or
eic is an interstellar calendar
standardization adopted with the
establishment of the first off-earth
colony on mars in 1992 a.d zero eic it
was and is the predominant calendar used
throughout the known galaxy although
before the quiet rapture many debated
switching over to a more standardized
measurement of years imc or interstellar
martian calendar was especially popular
owing to a large population residing on
mars after the quiet rapture all
stations and starships alliances still
use eic aside from eden which uses imc
imc known commonly as imc the
interstellar martian calendar is an
alternative to the more widely used eic
it was poised to be officially adopted
by mars before the quiet rapture whereas
eic is based on the rotation of earth
imc is based on the rotation of mars
meaning that one year in imc is about
1.88 years in imc currently only eden a
former martian space station uses i am
imc
okay mars fourth planet from the sun
first off site colony mars was most
populated planted in the solar system
before the quiet rapture surpassing
earth in 143 eic
how the hell did they do that now all
that remains of mars former glory is the
eden space station
okay fascinating
quiet rapture in 357 eic without any
prior warning radio contact with our
respective planets was suddenly cut
nobody can recall having visual contact
with any planets when the incident
occurred or experiencing any other
unusual phenomena so it's uncertain what
might exactly have happened upon
investigation it was observed
independently by several stations that
there were that where there had
previously been planets
nothing remained
further investigation over the following
months revealed that all known planets
with sentient life flora and fauna and
habital a habitable atmosphere or any
sort of natural resources were likewise
gone along with all known stars the only
celestial bodies that have been found
since are either uninhabitable moons or
asteroids
many theories have been proposed for
this disaster including religious
interpretations of it as a literal
rapture or some kind unknown quantum
anomaly or something more cosmic and
sinister there are no concrete answers
yet
fascinating okay what is conviction
realization the humane form of criminal
justice used by the coi where crimes are
repaid by rendering service to the
general collective often this is
performing surveys maintenance or other
similarly beneficial tasks
excellent iron lung ah there's one the
sm-13 one of four in-service underwater
crafts fashioned by the coi for use in
conviction realization in the blood
oceans
it is designed for deep liquid
photography and analysis redacted all
rumors of the sm-13 and similar crafts
being used for so-called mob justice by
way of force suffocation or otherwise
have been proven false proven by whom
by whom did you prove this so it said
four moons there are other moons
there have to be other moons right
there have to be what is up here i don't
know if i ever made it up there i want
to go down here but also i want to go up
there let me go here first i want to go
to this area
not gonna pay that any mind
that's not my problem
i'm sorry
okay
probably fine
that's fine
not worried about that
not worried about that at all
just some banging on the hull
trying to say hello
that's fine
that's no problem
that's no problem at all
so that's probably whatever let me take
a look at whatever that is because it
looks like there's pillars here
fascinating so if i want to get to the
back corner it's about
755 760 by 100.
oh god
okay just looks like a whole lot of
nothing doesn't look like much of
anything looks like there's nothing down
here so really my curiosity is what is
up there
[Music]
fine definitely fine
100 fine
go right the fire
ah
good thing i heard that
fire
depth
no
i should have rammed it
i should have rammed it
i should have rammed it all right i need
to get to about 575 700
we're good
we're all good
[Music]
so i'm willing to bet
because i went up there what happens if
i go the other path
that's probably where the secrets lie
oh good the blood has arrived
great
okay i need 5.75
uh 575 750.
getting kind of
horrifying up in here
okay once i'm there i need to go to
6 25 7 75. so does this mean that the
rapture was ever human except for the
ones that are alive left less than a
thousand um got squooshed into blood
goop
is that the lore
the glorious lore almost there or
something
whatever almost there and there is and
we're there and almost there
okay so it's a real tight gap straight
through seven
maybe like 765
700 i think i just got to go buy the
radar on this one maybe some pictures
that's not helpful i'm just gonna go by
radar
okay that'll be the top wall
okay i'm i'm clear to seven six uh
actually seven fifteen seven six five
[Music]
okay we're starting to this is
oh this is a narrow gap this is quite
the threadage of the needle
okay
okay where are we
seven
750
730 749 we can go a little forward
okay what do we see what are we looking
at
oh nothing great i'm just gonna go to
the bottom of this which is about
ooh 775 700
getting real tight in here
we're getting close to the
what am i looking at
what am i looking at
wha what
sm 8
sm
8. sm eight oh
okay hopefully they don't redact this
before updating the database what most
people don't understand is that not all
subs are built equal the sm8 isn't a
burner sub it really is for exploring
and surveying blood oceans if they send
you down in the iron lung they don't
give a [ __ ] if you come back or if the
sub comes back because it's a pile of
garbage and you're a piece of [ __ ] you
come back with photos great you sit down
there and suffocate quietly even better
but if they send the sm8 down one of the
scientists is piloting and they all
expect them to return and now the sm8 is
in the blood ocean in pieces no not
hidden rock pieces or sprung elite
pieces it looks like something tore it
up and the weirdest thing is that nobody
else seems surprised we might have found
the first planetary life since the
rapture and they're acting like it's no
big deal i know you're next in line for
realization in the iron lung and usually
that means you won't be seeing the stars
again but they don't have an sm-8
anymore they have three burner subs and
a lot of curiosity about 85 and maybe
that means you have a chance
okay that's good i don't think i do but
hey the sm-8 so that's lying right here
on the map but that still leaves a
question about what's here
okay
okay getting here wherever here is
what the hell is that
what is that
okay
that's weird okay so i'm uh
850
828 so i'm about right here
that's a regular sound okay three is a
pattern
so what does that mean the outer bounds
are probably going to be like 900 850
so don't go past that
what
am i looking at
teeth
what
is this
i'm literally right on top of it let me
go forward and turn around and see the
other side of it maybe
that's a weird-ass tooth in the ground
okay well no idea what that's about so
all that's left down here is some weird
musical obelisk right down here i didn't
check up here
but i doubt that there's anything else
really extraordinary besides what would
be after this now the crazy thought the
crazy thing to do would be to try to hit
these things in reverse order because
you die
going up here what happens if i fly up
the ass of uh
whatever is up here you think that's
possible i can do that
or will it just kill me straight up
[Music]
sounds like a lot of things moving out
there
sounds like a lot of movement i am
hearing a lot of movement
just a whole lot of movement
just a lot of movement out there
what is that
what why do i hear that
i hear that
what is that
oh
i don't like the general shape of what
i'm seeing over here
oh god i hate this
what is going on
what am i looking at wait no no
no
no
what is it what is this
what am i looking at please tell me this
is
nothing oh no
oh what is that
is that the thing is that 626.75
yeah i think that's the thing whatever
that is
why is it crunchy
oh why is it so crunchy
ugh hate that
don't know what it is
but it's crunchy
oh god that jump scare is coming
okay 675 828.
here we go
oh no
oh no
don't do it
please i don't want to die
okay we're fine
i've played this before have i
what is that achievement i played this
before
okay so that's fascinating i did not die
so weirdly
i'm still alive so there might be
something
to going backwards through this but i
don't know if i would have enough oxygen
to do so i really do think that there
might be a limit to what you could do
but if there's a possibility that i can
survive this
by going in reverse order
i'm kind of curious about that
wait
huh three oh 325.
oh i'm dumb
saving progress for some reason it's
still saving
i don't know if that's on a timer
or what
mr crab leg whatever that's supposed to
be
the weird one over there okay so
what happens if you go in reverse order
do you die the same if you came all the
way back to the beginning would things
be bad or would they be okay i don't
know
i don't remember this sound from before
so i don't know what the deal is
okay i need to get the 185.76
okay there we go
well we're fine
oh that's not good
oh right this was wibbly wobbly
right
okay and then angle 184
wa bam
oh yeah the weird light the ghibli light
even the image is ghibli
right okay gonna back that ass up
i'm not gonna back that ass up i'm gonna
run away from dead ass currently running
away from dead ass goodbye
i guess i am doing these in reverse
order but again i don't know how much
longer my ship's gonna hold
okay and i moved
277 635 thanks i'll be on my way
okay
all right well that's a skellington
huh that's a big skellington
it's a very big skeleton what was this
thing
that doesn't matter okay that's four
down five six to go
560 277
angle 43
roger roger
it's probably just going to kill me at
the end i don't think there's any
recovering for this even if
like i think it's still just going to be
death by fish
oh hi
hi bud
hi
it's you oh boy
oh no
oh no
oh
goodness 6 13
97 okay
[Music]
not a whale you got it
this is fine
um that's the same as the other one
though that is the same look this looks
the same as that
in all honesty they look idemboogle
yeah
steamy steam
okay no bump apparently no bomb
doesn't want to bump me i don't know why
it's not bumping me but i'm not getting
bumped
oh i got bumped i got bumped i got
bumped okay so 5
76 350 576 350 okay
good
all right please
that's probably not good
great
296.
okay
hmm tubes
i let well i didn't get it 296 296
250 259 oopsies that's my bad
that's my bed
oops
them some good tubes love those tubes
really love the tubes all right 378 263
okay an angle 50.
i might not be the right angle
nope i got it
two faces and then the last one 322 186
and then i probably dies just the same
186
angle 33 and then this would be the last
one
okay
i knew it i
knew it i knew it i knew you were gonna
do that anyway i knew it i don't even
know why i bothered
i don't know why i bothered
i don't know why i bothered with all
that effort
all that work for the same result but at
least i checked it out now you don't
have to that's what i'm here for
[Music]
but we did get some more lore so i do
think this amounted to a worthwhile
endeavor even though that was uh
only partially successful but i'm gonna
consider it fully successful because
when you consider the success that i had
in getting all the things that i
intended to get i did those things and i
committed to it so that's what really
matters so thank you everybody so much
for watching i look forward to more
stuff in this universe because it is
inherently creepy and i want to see more
about it so thank you let me know what
you thought down in the comments below
and unless i missed something i got
beyond the veil i don't know what that
means did i get all the achievements
are there more achievements achievements
one locked achievements spatial
awareness i have not crashed into a wall
that's the only thing i didn't do
i guess i gotta do that let me see where
continue leaves me off all right 360.
280
oh oh i see where it is i should just be
able to go directly to my right 90
degrees and slam into that wall
let's go slam a wall
what i've always dreamed of here we go
man you really uh i'm not sure if you
touch a wall you'll die but uh i smacked
into that wall full of speed and died so
thank you everybody so much for watching
i am completionist about this game now
and unless there are some diary entries
in the computer terminal that i have not
found
i've seen it all thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you